hi my name is Deborah hang on i'm the
co-founder and executive director of the
golden baobab I'd like to address a
Nadine hacks comment on one year one
change about how intergenerational
dialogue among emerging leaders and
elder leaders is needed in Africa and
everywhere everywhere else in the world
I totally agree i think change can only
can only come about as a collaboration
between especially in Africa the older
leaders on the younger generation where
the younger generation can can bring the
zeal and the passion that they have
foreseen ivetta Africa and coupled that
with the experience and wisdom of the
older generation and and put that
together to to bring to bring impactful
change I think if young people are you
know I think it absolutely the future of
Africa belongs to young people and young
people are dictating what the terms of
change are but I think it can only true
change and an impactful change can only
come about us as a collaboration between
young and